[Music]
is carbon capture a help or a hindrance
from my point of view
it's a little bit of column and a little
bit of column b i don't think at this
stage we really have a plan of getting
to net zero without
some
role for carbon capture and storage
there is this
sense that for some industries like
steel and cement it's going to be very
difficult for them to get to absolute
zero
but what should the role of ccs be for
the oil and gas sector for example is
much harder to agree on
long term you really need to change so
many things about our system rather than
using the same old existing fossil fuel
sources of energy and then finding a
really expensive solution to how to deal
with their emissions
we're starting from a place where
there's already too much co2 in the
atmosphere so you need negative emission
technologies to remove that last piece
and until we have scale of renewable
this is an important element in
decarbonising the use of oil and gas
in many ways it can be a part of how we
address the problem
but it can't be a magic cure to climate
change
[Music]
[Music]
carbon capture carbon capture pump food
carbon capture carbon
technology the relatively new miracle of
carbon capture and and storage there's a
lot of talk about carbon capture right
now from companies from governments
there's been a lot more investment in
this sector we saw the u.s allocate
billions of dollars to ccs and give a
tax credit to carbon capture and storage
projects because the world hasn't
reduced emissions 40 billion tons a year
it means that the timeline for a tipping
point in warming which is regarded as
1.5 degrees is nearing and governments
policymakers businesses are all really
scrambling now that means they're
turning to
most obvious solutions there is some
pushback to that though where people say
look this is not a silver bullet
and the number of ccs facilities that
are actually operational is pretty small
they don't capture
in the grand scheme of things that much
carbon
in 2021 there's around 40 million tons
of co2 captured by existing ccs projects
if the world is to be on the right path
for net zero that number would need to
rise to around 1.7 billion tons of co2
by around 20 30. so that's a 40x
increase in just the next eight years
to effectively capture carbon
you have to get it from the source and
so therefore you need to have the
facility where the emission is coming
from some of the biggest proponents and
investors in ccf projects have been oil
and gas companies it is the oil and gas
industry which has the capability to
actually find the stores for the co2 and
to physically store it and most of the
oil and gas companies including ecuador
have been operating offshore for very
many years so those capabilities
together uh is is a big element of the
ccs norway started with this already in
the 1990s they've got a north sea oil
and gas platform where they've been
pumping co2 into the seabed since 1996.
for the slate neural field and and snowy
together we have avoided co2 emissions
for 25 years of one to two million
dollars per year so quite a bit of
experience
but then in 2007
8 they tried something that the prime
minister then jen stoltenberg called
norway's moon landing a full-scale
carbon capture plant on a new combined
heat and power plant on our west coast
this has never been done before
and we are poised to do it well
unfortunately it didn't quite go as well
as neil armstrong and they had to
abandon it after spending billions and
billions of kroner so they've got a lot
of experience but it's just it's
essentially uneconomical to do at any
scale whether it's the the carbon
capture scale or it's the transport
scale
and the storage scale all those are
driven
to lower economic costs by increasing
the size the key question is how we make
that economic and how you incentivize
companies when it's an expensive process
and there's no actual economic driver
for them to do that
once you capture the carbon
what do you do with the carbon
in theory in lots of projects you just
bury it underground you put it under the
sea and that's great but that's not a
revenue source but if a use can be found
for this co2
a commercial use that would also make
the economics a lot more attractive
carbon capture and storage is what it
says on the tin it's a capture of the
carbon and storing it underground
then there is its sister which is carbon
capture usage and storage dc us is where
some of that captured carbon dioxide is
actually reused in industries where
carbon dioxide is absolutely crucial and
where there isn't currently an answer
for actually replacing its usage your
soda is fizzy because of co2 that is
stripped out of these
uh industrial plants that can be used in
products like fertilizer plastics and
things that were really you know
important to industry and that's a
viable business model that's one that's
you know can support itself
and sell the co2 to an industrial user
we saw last year when a fertilizer plant
in the northeast of england was closed
down
which actually was a big producer carbon
dioxide as well there was then sudden
panic about a whole range of vital vital
industries such as the food processing
industry you know how they were going to
get the co2 that's desperately needed in
those industries
but it still is tinkering at the edges
it seems to me of a much bigger problem
and it is not going to be the answer to
the masses of carbon dioxide that are
emitted from fossil fuel extraction in
the first place or from the burning of
other carbon producing fuels
enhanced oil recovery has been one of
the single biggest uses of captured co2
where you take pressurized co2 and you
pump it back into old oil wells to
increase the pressure inside the reserve
and therefore dislodge the remaining
hydrocarbon so ironically in many ways a
technology that is used at the moment to
try and kind of
limit the worst effects of global
warming to try and combat climate change
was developed in the first place to
produce more fossil fuels and that seems
quite antithetical to how it's being
talked about by governments or by the
iea that's not really i think what most
people think it should be used for or is
being used for the environmental
community is arguing that it's
counterintuitive you're capturing carbon
and then injecting it into a reservoir
in order to produce more hydrocarbons
and then burn it and create more carbon
so what's the point how about
don't dig that hydrocarbon up whatsoever
don't burn it
[Applause]
the oil industry argues that enhanced
oil recovery has been benefit
because they are storing carbon
oxy for over 50 years have been really
the world's largest handler of co2 20
million tons a year
in terms of volume and they argue that
they have a unique skill set around ccs
where they can really play a leading
role in pushing these things forward a
particularly interesting example is
occidental petroleum which is seeking to
use its expertise in that field to
capture and store those emissions that
are produced by the company's operations
and its suppliers but also in theory
enough
carbon emissions to offset whatever oil
was burned by its customers and the
emissions that that created 90 of the
carbon footprint of the big oil
companies comes when their products are
burnt so that's really changed the
calculus for them and has meant they've
had to rethink ccs as a technology and
now exploring ways in which to really
expand that at scale today we have
chosen uh to partner with carbon
engineering a great large scale
technology for for direct air capture to
create a true cost solution and that's
the ability to take a million tons per
plant
directly out of the air we have a plan
between 70 and 135 plants
by
2035 which we believe is very important
to address this problem i think the
question is always how much trust do
those oil companies have having been at
the center of some of the biggest
emissions over the last three decades
and been at the center of a really
contentious effort to push back in some
cases against environmental
strategies over the past 30 years and i
think the worry is that
if you
overly focus on ccs and if you seem to
have this quick fix
do you just go first for that rather
than changing your processes to make
them less energy intensive or carbon
intensive
[Music]
the key problem
with carbon capture as
many environmentalists see it is that
fossil fuel producers can continue to
operate as they are operating now
and without having to
overhaul the way they do things because
any emissions that are produced can just
be sucked back up
environmentalists and climate change
experts and scientists actually not to
make them all sound like they're tree
huggers
believe that
the first priority should be the
reduction of carbon emissions in the
atmosphere and i think that's what we
need to really get across and what the
big oil companies needs to probably
understand is that if we don't reduce
oil and gas production and consumption
then we're not going to hit net zero
2050.
industry and the ia quite quickly and
others will say that
no matter what fossil fuels are going to
be around for for decades to come and
ccs could be a really critical way of
decarbonizing this
other people say
we don't actually
need that coal and gas
full stop we can get to net zero without
worrying about the fossil fuels and that
side would argue that actually ccs is a
bit of a distraction they're worried
about cost should the money that's going
towards carbon capture and storage
actually be
used to try and really accelerate even
further
offshore wind deployment or onshore wind
deployment or solar or other clean
energy technologies renewable is
developed today
at scale and we really believe in win
but we need much larger scale of
renewable and
until we have that scale of renewable we
would need ccs to bridge that
[Music]
you're not going to bring down emissions
with ccs alone but i think ultimately
what we should now recognize is even if
we managed to
cut emissions to to net zero by 2040 10
years early at that point we'd still
have a huge amount of carbon in the
atmosphere that we'd want to try and
pull out negative emissions technology
is any type of system that is reducing
the overall co2 in the atmosphere so
whether that's direct air capture for
example take the co2 out pump it
underground or other approaches such as
bio energy capture and storage one of
the biggest proposals
for this is is in the uk at drax we have
a publicly stated ambition to have 12
million tons of negative emissions
before 2030 8 million of that would be
here at drax power station and bex
underpins that ambition
drax having been once europe's biggest
emitter it was a huge coal-fired power
station has converted to biomass and
it's now developing becks horrible word
but basically means bio energy with
carbon capture and storage so combining
those means
in theory it's carbon negative as you've
got a neutral baseline and then you've
got this thing removing more carbon so
it becomes
negative in theory if you start with a
tree the tree is growing in the forest
it absorbs co2 as it grows that co2 is
stored in its wood that's turned into a
wood pellet which is then burned the co2
is then captured and injected into the
ground that whole process has resulted
in principle in a net negative cn2
impact we need negative emissions in the
uk the net zero 2050 strategy sets out
the very clear 5 million ton negative
emission number required by 2030 our
project is perfectly shaped to fill that
ambition you know it's probably the
cheapest way you can get to upscale
negative emissions with the least amount
of work why wouldn't you bex and just uh
biomass in general even before we get to
vex has been hugely controversial some
just think it's colorful carbon
accounting at the crux what you have to
know is whether the biomass energy that
is produced is carbon neutral
if you can prove that it is
then bex can be a negative emissions
technology but if you can't and until
you can
then we shouldn't put all of this money
and time and effort into growing a
beck's pipeline you do that on the
expectation that it's going to be
operational for decades
and
so doing that locks it into the system
for decades
one of the really big changes we've seen
in the carbon capture space is the
emergence of this idea of having
hubs as they're usually called here in
the u.s or clusters as they're often
called the uk and europe the idea of a
cluster
probably does make sense you've got
different operators that do different
things sort of sharing infrastructure
it's just making the whole system more
efficient you could see why that makes
sense
they're going to make a lot of sense in
areas where you have a high
industrialized area with multiple
industries that can
manage the storage together share the
cost of the transport norway is trying
to develop a big
project currently in the north sea
there's a store or
a less charitable way of describing it
as a graveyard for co2
for a lot of for a lot of uh europe at
the moment it's a relatively modest
project
but they say it has the potential to
store i think it's a sort of a thousand
annual emissions of norway under the
seabed uh and then you've got the
creatively titled zero carbon humber in
the uk
in the humber area we're working
together 12 companies to put in place
infrastructure that is required for them
to decarbonize and have the opportunity
to transport the co2 to the store we
have to reduce carbon emissions from
industrial sources from electricity
production sources we absolutely have to
do that but we're still going to be left
with a
hard to abay sectors where we've got
residual emissions that we can't do
there's lots of them steel ceramics
chemicals
where it's just not easy to envisage at
the moment how actually
they're going to be able to exist in in
a net zero world so there's a definitely
a case to be made that these
technologies will save some of those
industries and
without it
it's very difficult to see what will
happen what people don't realize is that
you know 85 percent of our emissions
uh are the result of the heat to drive
our processes it makes steam it's heat
to drive furnaces it's heat to drive
rotating equipment
and that's why you have to think about
how can i use different fuel sources
that can generate that heat with a
carbon freeway we will also help
providing hydrogen if that is helping
them uh to reduce their emissions we're
not going to be able to use electricity
for everything so for the things that
you can't use electricity for then
you're going to need a molecule and i
think that molecule is going to be
hydrogen
[Music]
in many ways
the
development of an optimism or moraine
carbon capture goes hand in hand with
the development of an optimism around
hydrogen as a future energy solution
there's a big increase in hydrogen
investment right now and forecasts show
that hydrogen consumption will
need to increase
as we
move towards net zero
emissions hydrogen is a perfectly clean
fuel to burn
when you burn it no co2 is emitted so
you can feed hydrogen into power station
instead of natural gas
so making the power generation clean and
then we can use hydrogen as a reduction
agent
very technical into the steel industry
so they can use hydrogen instead of coal
in their processes
there's two main ways to produce it one
is using clean energy and that leads to
what we call green hydrogen
you can also make hydrogen from natural
gas
along with ccs that removes the
emissions from the chemical process and
that's called blue hydrogen we cannot
produce clean or green hydrogen
in large enough quantities and a slow
enough cost for all of the applications
for which hydrogen might be needed and
so until that comes down i do think blue
hydrogen can be a useful bridging fuel
to increase adoption of hydrogen as a
option
blue hydrogen is a nice label but it
still doesn't get away from the fact
that you're emitting carbon to produce a
gas so
it it
doesn't to me seem to be a huge
uh advance
again
hydrogen is it being over hyped
because if we start replacing absolutely
everything with hydrogen then we will
continue to rely on fossil fuel
companies extracting gas
because you know we will have created so
many industries with hydrogen at the
core
that we we won't be able to wean
ourselves off blue hydrogen
[Music]
to make sure we reach the climate goals
and the paris agreement
we need to use all the tools in the
toolbox
those being ccs it's blue hydrogen it's
green hydrogen it's electrification and
it is wind and solar
this is the way to decarbonize
our society
there is room for some of these
technologies in areas where the industry
for all its best efforts cannot
transform itself quickly enough but even
for those industries over time it must
become more expensive for them to
deal in carbon so that other
technologies become more viable
renewable energy becomes more viable
it's absolutely right that we shouldn't
use one to avoid doing the other what we
need to do is deploy both in parallel
and i think that's what that's what the
industry and most industries are trying
to achieve
the climate crisis is so acute the need
for massive investment is so great but i
don't think we can be too picky about
who advances what technology and who's
in charge it's too early to take options
off the table
i personally see carbon capture as
critical to delivering on carbon
neutrality for our industry and actually
society but at the end of the day
i do see it as a critical part of the
transition and a role of it i think will
diminish over time
supporters of carbon capture and storage
you know the next few years are going to
be absolutely crucial for them to show
that these are technologies that are
viable that they can deliver the capture
rates that they promise
that costs can come down they've got to
prove that that actually will happen
and i think that will decide whether
this is the right moment and you know
ccs is in the sweet spot or whether
ccs again looks a bit of
expensive white elephant
you